[Music]
okay well it's a pleasure to be here I
had prepared a PowerPoint but I thought
that would probably be a little too
formal but I thought I would begin by
the slide of Hannah
Erin who is one of the great historians
student of Hitler noxee in the origins
of totally narrow Teheran air
totalitarianism and what she said is
what makes it possible for a
totalitarian or any other dictatorship
to rule is that people are not informed
how can you have an opinion if you are
not informed but this is the point that
is really important if everybody always
lies to you
the consequence is not that you believe
the lies but rather than that nobody
believes anything any longer and that
really gives the context for what has
been happening in the United States with
Trump he is a liar and surrounded
himself with the liars
but it's not that anybody believes
anything he says but they've given up
weaving in anything and so there's been
an attack on our institutions of
knowledge that was a very I think well
described in some of the previous
sessions this morning where they
described the attack on our institutions
of like Education Free Press science
underlying all this is an attack on what
might be called epistemology what it is
that we know and how we ascertain that
now the reason this is so important it
can go big brought back to the
Enlightenment that's been raised a
couple of times again did the
Enlightenment
really represented the break historical
break in our understandings it developed
the scientific method again that was
talked about this morning and the
scientific method was a method for
ascertaining the truth and there's
several aspects of it that have been
brought out the fact it's based on trust
with verification when we say we believe
in climate change I'm sure none of you
who have read through the huge
literature you couldn't be you wouldn't
be here if you were reading the
literature just but you trust and why do
you trust because there's been a system
of data open other people can verify it
so it's not that you just trust somebody
the it's the date has been made
available there's this replication the
replicability experimentation it's all
based on the system you might call it
open transparency and the benefits of
this have been enormous if you look at
what happened to standards of living for
literally centuries before that there
have been no change and the big break
was the Enlightenment with the
scientific method we began to learn how
to do things better and that led to
increases our standard of living very
dramatic so in a way you might say isn't
it curious that the very thing that has
brought us to the prosperity that we
have is now being attacked by Trump and
by the Republican Party and obviously
it's very disturbing to those of us who
are committed to science and advancement
of progress to see this assault on our
piston illogical institutions or
institutions of knowledge it has
consequences for both our economy and
for our democracy in terms of our
economy
the best experiment evidence of this you
can see is what happened in the 2008
crisis the banks were very non
transparent the banks knew that they
were cheating and lying and when the
crisis occurred they knew that they
couldn't trust anybody they couldn't
trust themselves where they knew they
somewhat nobody should trust them but
they also knew that they couldn't trust
anybody else so what happened no bank
would lend to any other bank and the
whole financial system froze and our
economies went into the great recession
so it is a it was a consequence of the
breakdown of trust for our democracy
it's exactly the same thing we talked
about the rule of law due process well
all these things require knowing what
some version of the truth is we have we
want out
did somebody commit the murder but we
also want to know has he been treated
fairly if it's all a matter of one
person's judgment of versus another we
can't have any system of rule of law we
can't have any system we cannot have a
democracy so the the the importance of
trust for the functioning of our economy
and for the functioning of our democracy
and our society is absolutely vital now
to me the modern assault on trust and
the scientific method my might really be
traced back to climate change and I
mentioned that this morning the reason
that was so important was so much money
was at stake and it was so clear what
the science was saying the science was
saying that the continuation of the use
of fossil fuels was going to have these
very serious consequences and
and that meant people like the Koch
brothers who had an economic interest in
not pursuing the consequences it was
inconvenient truth is Al Gore Assad
began they couldn't deny the science
they began denying the validity of the
institutions the scientific institutions
themselves so in a way that that that
was what began the assault but there
were it fed on to other historical
episodes of that one was about a half
century ago when evidence came that
cigarettes were very bad for your health
and the scientific evidence was
unambiguous it was an inconvenient truth
for the cigarette companies and they
began an assault on the science they
began an assault of skepticism there so
it hadn't been proven even though with
any degree of reliability it had been
proven so they had a monitoring center
to do that and then the other episode
was the attack on evolution which many
people from religious background thought
evolution was an attack on their
fundamental religious belief the reason
I mentioned that is because that's an
example where there was a contradiction
between truth paestum allow systems of
beliefs and religious beliefs and
ideology and that plays out in the
current context in the debate about the
beliefs in the market and the private
government's ability to address the
problems well the title of the session
is the fragility of truth and what I
want to argue is that actually our
systems are not very robust our systems
of truth are actually very fragile what
do I mean by that well some systems are
what we call dynamically stable you
perturb the system for
them and they quickly get restored but
some systems are fragile are dynamically
unstable ecological systems tend to be
often unstable if you if you fish too
much the number of fish gets below a
critical level and you get extinction so
that's an example of at least if you
have too big of a perturbation the
system doesn't restore itself yet it
goes into another situation which is not
the good one that we originated in I
think what worries me is that in a sense
the institutions of trust and science
have that same kind of fragility and
it's for the reasons that I just
explained that first the institutions of
truth have to compete with liars and
David gross gave that point this morning
that people the liars can give a sense
of confidence comfort for the now for
the short run that people want whereas
the scientific institutions always begin
by saying well there's some degree of
uncertainty and often uncomfortable is a
uncomfortable truth
so the liars can frame their message to
what the people want to hear and the
other side feels constrained about by
the truth and that's an unfair
competition in the short run hopefully
you in the long run people will
understand this but in the short run
that's what we're we're up against they
can give a a false sense of certainty
the second is that the money is on the
side in many cases of not the truth so
climate change Illustrated that but in
the current context one of the
mechanisms by which there's been the
assault on truth as a social media and
the social media companies
have a vested interest in a technology
which makes the truth more fragile one
of the problems is hurting behavior bad
false news can move very quickly many
examples you may you know the the
Hillary Clinton is a pedophile and the
pieces story in the United States spread
very very rapidly there are lots of
examples of the spread of bad news these
false news very rapidly and they the
private companies like that because that
gets more clicked that gets more
advertising that gets more money so the
underlying architecture that leads to it
is sometimes called hypocrisy ruled by
by Ops is profit maximizing and that
means that we're not going to get a
private sector solution but it's worse
than that the private sector has an
incentive to try to persuade everybody
that the government can't solve the
problem that you the solutions that
would entail government regulation would
make you worse off so they can use their
money in an unlevel way to feed on to
the ideology the government doesn't work
and so they're trying to create an image
that yes this is a problem they'll
acknowledge it but leave it to us to fix
well we know they're not going to fix it
that is against their interest unless a
lot of public pressure is brought about
now then that that leads the next
question actually could we do something
to stop especially the problems created
by the social media I think the answer
is unambiguously yes there are many
things that we can do not necessarily
perfect fixes but they would make things
much better but here's the problem many
of the things that we might do to
correct the problem
could be abused and have been abused by
authoritarian regimes so some of the
restrictions that you might impose are
the kinds of things that are you know
that you could imagine being abused but
that's life in general anything that is
good can also almost everything is a
two-edged sword and we have to create
institutions that circumscribe the
abuses of the things that are intended
to circumscribe other abuses we get
checks and balances that's the part of a
democracy so to give you one example of
something that has been done by some
countries in Europe already hate speech
Germany is out loud loud hate speech now
that kind of provision can be abused a
totalitarian government could reclassify
anything that they didn't like as hate
speech so we have to recognize that we
are dealing with something that could be
abused but there are some things that
where the probability of abuse is low
and the mechanisms of checks and
balances to prevent the abuses are not
that difficult let me just give you a
couple examples so one thing is there
are ways of checking the speed with
which bad ideas get propagated there are
ways of requiring some degrees of
verification or at least disclosure of
information who bought the I so you
disclosed the ad so what I want to say
is that there are actually a whole set
of measures some of one of which is
being discussed in the US Congress now
that are I don't want to say they're
perfect solutions but they prevent some
of the worst abuses that we have seen in
fake news in the context of the social
media the final thing I want to just
conclude is
Wow science reminds us that we don't
know things for certain that doesn't
mean that everything is of equal truth
value that is to say we know that
climate change is going to occur with a
probability you know point nine nine
nine nine nine nine we could be OMA
certain and we could almost be certain
that those who are the climate change
deniers are wrong so the fact that we're
not a hundred percent certain about
things doesn't mean that all views have
equal validity and this is really
important because that in the any say in
the fog of the lack of certainty there
are many people who are trying to to
Trump is trying to say okay now I've
denied I've shown that the others are
fake news that describes it's all
knowledge and that nihilism will lead to
an undermining of our society and our
democracy and so what we really have to
work to is to create institutions of
trust trust in that that we have ways of
telling things that are true or almost
certainly true from those that are lies
and almost certainly lies and and that's
really how to do that within a
democratic society without opening
ourselves up to the potential abuses is
the critical issue before us now so
truth is fragile but we can protect
ourselves from the assault that the
Trump administration is trying to have
on our truth thank you
[Applause]